so
still far from their dreams of returning
home more than a million refugees are
stuck in the hills of Cox Bazaar
Muhammad Bella lost everything when he
left Myanmar and he doesn't believe its
military leaders are serious about
helping people like him to return
they have no real intention to take us
it's all a show we're appealing to the
International Community for justice if
justice prevails only then will we go
back
last week a delegation of officials from
the military regime met some rohingya
considered eligible to return to Myanmar
as early as next month but most rohingya
are skeptical meanwhile delegation that
came recently does not have any real
intent to take us back they came here
only for show due to the increase in
international pressure two previous
attempts to repatriate refugees since
2017 have failed and talks to attempt
another have been suspended since the
Myanmar military staged the coup in
2021. many refugees believe the
political situation in Myanmar is too
volatile for them to go back now
we faced many difficulties here like
limited rations of essential food items
lack of proper Medical Care Etc so we do
want to go back but only when there is
peace
Roy Yasin is a rohingya journalist who
documents events in this Camp there
livelihood days now opportunities and
facilities for the refugees to survive
here so all of the refugees want to go
back home with the dignified return
Safety and Security Myanmar retains the
sole authority to verify those who can
return an issue identity cards to them
based on evidence of past residence
rohinga do not have citizenship in their
home country Myanmar and also on
recognized as indigenous they're only
issued with so-called National
verification card identifying them as
Bengali Muslims but most rohingya here
left all their possessions behind or
their homes were burned down or looted
so they cannot produce such proof of
former residents and rights groups say
Myanmar has done little to support
rohingya citizenship to instill
confidence in those wanting to return
home sanvi Chaudhry Al Jazeera Cox's
Bazaar